hey crazies it's time for photons this
episode was made possible by generous
supporters on patreon I imagine a lot of
you feel like you know what a photon is
it's just a packet of energy or whatever
but you know what happens when you
assume you make a mistake sometimes
calling a photon a packet of energy
isn't wrong it's just not very useful
because everything is a packet of energy
I have something in this box can you
guess what it is no here's a hint it's a
collection of atoms did that help
probably not surprise it's a squirrel my
point is there's a better way to
describe photons yes it's a packet of
energy but it's the details about that
energy that make it a photon hmm how
should we tackle this I think the
top-down approach is going to work best
we're Junction is basically it's the
idea of starting with something
normal-sized and then breaking it up
until you find its smallest pieces what
you might call its elementary pieces
honestly this is how we came up with
quantum physics in the first place
so it seems like a great place to start
elementary particles are like bite-sized
pieces of something ordinary kind of
like how this video series comes in
bite-sized pieces of quantum physics
it's almost like I planned this or
something anyway a photon is the
smallest piece of light like you might
find coming out of a flashlight like
this can I have the flashlight do you
remember what happened the last time I
gave a flashlight to a clone I wonder
what this button does turn it off turn
it off
behave what if I promise to behave all
right we'll try this one more time okay
back to business a beam of light is one
of those normal sized things I was
talking about earlier it's something we
can see with our eyes something the size
of us but if we're going to understand
it like a quantum physicist physicist
physic physicist we need to break it
into smaller and smaller parts until we
find something we can't break anymore
light beams are giant collections of
many electromagnetic waves if we focus
on one of those waves
we can see a repeating pattern one cycle
of that pattern looks like this
that's one wavelength of that wave there
really isn't anything smaller than this
for a wave is that what a photon is then
no we have a slight problem light waves
can be anywhere on the e/m spectrum
including the low frequency end like
radio waves a single radio wavelength
can be as large as a small city I find
it hard to believe that a single photon
could ever be that big maybe we're
looking at this all wrong
seem to remember seeing something
important earlier yes it's a packet of
energy but it's the details about that
energy that make it a photon right this
isn't about the space something takes up
elementary particles like photons don't
really have any size anyway this is
about energy it's the energy we have to
break into pieces let's start with a
standard incandescent light bulb this
one is 60 watts that means it transforms
60 joules of electrical energy into heat
and light every second incandescent
bulbs are terribly inefficient though so
only about 10% of that actually becomes
light when you turn it on 6 joules of
light leave the ball every second but
that spreads out in all possible
directions eventually we're going to see
gaps between those pieces those tiny
little pieces of light energy are called
photons but the amount of energy they
have is very small you can calculate it
using e equals H F the H is Planck's
constant which is extremely small the F
is frequency which tells you what type
of light it is and in the visible range
it tells you color so the energy of a
photon is a constant times its color for
that 60 watt light bulb that's 10
million trillion photons per second wow
that's a lot of photons
since individual photons don't have that
much energy you have to get really far
away to notice the gaps between them
let's say you move away from the Sun and
an unimaginable speed and somehow manage
to avoid any of Einstein's relativity
eventually way out in space you'll start
to notice the sun's light flicker what
you're seeing are individual photons
actually here an optic nerve doesn't
send the signal to the brain unless nine
full-time to arrive within 100
milliseconds you have to ruin everything
don't you
I don't ruin things I make them more
accurate all right so humans can't see
individual photons but that actually
explains a few things
if you move away from the Sun like we
did earlier you can't see the flicker of
the photons so at about 750 light years
the sun's light will just fade away into
the blackness of space
that's why the night sky is mostly black
lit by just a few nearby stars the rest
of the photons are just too infrequent
for us to see so what the heck is a
photon right right stay focused Nick
there are a lot of little packets of
energy floating around in the universe
what makes them photons is all in the
details my dear crazies photons have a
specific set of properties that make
them photons a charge of zero
a spin of one with two possible
orientations and lastly a rest mass of
zero which makes many things about
photons possible their speed of almost
300 million meters per second their
energy being proportional to their
momentum and their inability to
experience time or space any little
packet of energy with those properties
is by definition a photon so got any
questions please ask in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and from one packet
of energy to another remember it's okay
to be a little crazy several people
asked about the red-blue kind of 3d
glasses one they're not red and blue
they're red and cyan because those are
opposite colors together they make white
too they use color filters to block one
of the images instead of polarisers so
they don't really work on color images
only black and white ones anyway crazies
thanks for watching